la commanderie d'elancourt faisait sa
rentrée ce samedi 11 septembre avec au
programme un événement baptisé welcome
objectif présenter la nouvelle saison
culturelle au grand public c'est la joie
et on a pu constater du public qui est
venu nous voir tous aux membres de
l'équipe nous dire à quel point il était
heureux qu on ouvre à nouveau les portes
la joie des artistes aussi qu'il soit
plasticiens danseurs jongleurs qui sont
présents avec nous aujourd'hui
comédienne qui en comme nous ce goût de
réouvrir les saisons et de redémarrer
cette rentrée était également attendue
par les artistes présents danseurs
chanteurs mêmes comédiens ils ont
retrouvé ce jour là la scène forcément
on est très heureux de jouer de
rencontrer les gens de voir qu'il ya du
monde et d'aller au contact du public
surtout la danse est dans cette forme
est de voir l'accueil très positif pour
ce rendez vous le public a répondu
présent avec plusieurs centaines de
personnes ce samedi oui ça fait plaisir
forcément surtout quand on est jeune de
pouvoir sortir c'est agréable même si là
y'a pas beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes mais
c'est sympa ça se passe très bien c'est
très sympa il ya beaucoup de monde la
musique est bonne tout se passe bien
prochain rendez-vous à la commanderie
d'elancourt le week end du 17 et 18
septembre pour les journées du
patrimoine